we've been graced with the playful
Millie moment since we first caught a
glimpse of behind the scenes footage of
stranger things Millie Bobby Brown has
been playing tricks and taking dance
breaks on set for years now and she's
even gone so far as to design a style of
movie making that takes this playfulness
into account stick around for bloopers
and cute onset moments from Enola homes
too Millie Bobby Brown
just in case they forgot number one one
camera is always rolling Millie Bobby
Brown has been busy promoting Enola
homes too and while for most that might
mean putting in the work once the
production is finished we feel like
Millie starts her promoting work by
capturing her Antics on set Millie's
brother Charlie was charged with the
task of following her on set with a
camera in order to capture all the
Antics and any other side messages
Millie wanted to deliver to us the
behind the scenes audience
oh I haven't been recording I've just
been trying to test my focus but I can
number two all we can say is ow in a
signature Milly moment on set Millie
expresses how she felt about working
with actor Lewis Partridge by saying
this I prefer hitting him
what they make me kiss him Lewis's
response to this playful moment was she
just had a curly Worley
uh
now that is chemistry number three
Winnie the Pooh and Dior on set of Enola
homes too is this some kind of
collaboration no Millie Bobby Brown just
brought her two dogs to set as we can
see here in a cab ride to Portsmouth to
shoot a scene these two can be found in
a number of onset moments including the
jail scene where the wall explodes we
wonder what they thought of that big
moment were they the ones calling action
number four how do you get Enola homes
to climb a drain pipe get Millie Bobby
Brown to do it arriving at a dead end in
an Alleyway Enola Holmes finds that her
only way out is up the drain pipe the
simplest way to get it done was just to
have Millie climb the pipe and Billy
explained for safety precautions we put
a wire on has anyone thought about
nicknaming her Millie the monkey number
five is this a musical no Millie's just
on set the Antics never end and
sometimes they even escalate as far as
an impromptu song and dance session in
this behind the scenes clip we see
Millie and Lewis and others in what
looks like their makeup trailer breaking
out into a costumed karaoke version of
[Music]
this clip is all we want for Christmas
number six what's your favorite scene in
Enola homes ever wondered which is
Millie's favorite Millie Bobby Brown
tells us that one of her absolute faves
in Enola homes 2 is the jail scene the
actress described it as this is a true
collaboration of women that come
together to help a nola Escape we can't
lie we dug it number seven just like
Enola would Inola homes has made herself
out to be a very direct character who
wastes no time with silly delays it
seems like Millie wasted no time in
rehearsal either describing the kiss
scene in The Carriage with Tewksbury
Millie said right on the Raja so I
wrapped his face and kissed him in his
room recalling the moment Millie
imitated Lewis's surprised face and said
it was so cute now that's one kind of
method acting number eight those stunts
are very convincing but wait is she
actually punching him in the carriage
scene between Enola and Tewksbury Millie
said she playfully took things a little
too far because Louis is a good friend I
just kept punching him you know I I
wouldn't I wasn't doing stunts I really
was hurting him and by the end of it he
said Milly can you just fake punch me
Millie laughed when she described the
moment explaining I was fully just
kidding him right in the stomach ah yes
acting a contact sport number nine for
once they asked her to dance with all
the onset dancing we saw behind the
scenes of stranger things Millie must
have been waiting for this moment the
story of Enola homes 2 finds Enola at a
ball where she needs to learn to dance
but dancing is not one of my core
strengths in the scene Inola conscripts
Tewksbury for a crash course on the
topic of Waltzing but the actors needed
to learn to waltz in rehearsal first
wait that's not a waltz maybe they just
need a break from the subject matter and
to Freestyle a bit number 10. she might
have been asked to dance but Millie's
still waiting on her invitation to sing
in the meantime she and her cast mates
and those of us watching the behind the
scenes coverage we'll just have to enjoy
rare moments like this one where Millie
and Louie sing a little excerpt from
Hamilton the musical while they wait for
the camera and crew to set up the next
shot they were not throwing away this
shot
number eleven she's more than an actor
on this one working as an actor and a
producer on Enola homes 2 seems to have
Millie Bobby Brown thinking like a
filmmaker she commented on the
difficulty of working in central London
when shooting Inola homes too saying it
is
I think that to London is the noise you
don't get one clean take for that
Lewis Partridge agreed and added okay
number 12. somehow being on set with
Millie means there is always time for a
playful moment it could be a trick an
impromptu karaoke moment or even a short
dance break in this behind the scenes
clip Milly and friends are in costume
and doing a dance together a rehearsal
for a choreographed scene or just a
quick Tick-Tock moment between takes you
never know with Millie number 13. she
knew where to find it Millie Bobby Brown
said that she pulled inspiration from
Phoebe Waller bridge and fleabag for
Enola Holmes too Millie talked about
Phoebe's performance and her inspiration
it's just like the perfect way to break
the fourth wall with her wit her humor
her timing it's so inspirational to me
number 14. every good room has one
breaking the fourth wall means talking
to or addressing the camera as though
the character is aware the camera is
watching sometimes this means addressing
the camera as though it is another
character free Nola homes 2 Millie Bobby
Brown said they again pulled inspiration
from fleabag and used director Harry
bradbeer for guidance Millie said I
think in every scene we tried doing we
tried breaking the fourth wall and then
Harry bradbeer edited the ones that
landed the most number 15. bring in the
expert
Millie was so inspired by Phoebe's
performance and the style of fleabag
that they even brought fleabag director
Harry bradbeer on board for Enola homes
too mbb talked about the decision to
bring Harry bradbeer on board for Enola
homes saying I know that Harry has
worked so closely with Phoebe in the
past so it's been a blessing to have him
guide me on such a great course of how
to achieve it
sometimes everyone for watching and I'll
see you all very soon
Millie Bobby Brown has been Charming us
with behind the scenes Antics for years
now starting all the way back with
stranger things wild tricks and dance
breaks probably work to keep the morale
high on stranger things we're very glad
that it continued free Nola homes too as
well now we can't have captured all the
Millie moments for Enola homes too so
what did we miss what are some of your
favorite Millie moments let us know in
the comments